ce soir notre invité principal c'est
patrick balkany mais
non
énorme c'est énorme on se croirait au
stade de france et du monde
patrick balkany bonsoir j'ai discuté
maire ump de levallois perret est-ce que
vous reconnaissez les faits
je me suis même habitué maire depuis 83
députés du 88 mon patrick vous
connaissez la procédure vous avez le
droit de garder le silence j'avais droit
à l'assistance d'un avocat vous
connaissez burbure le silence
et lambiel
même en deux ans
[Musique]
patrick balkany donc re bonsoir vous
êtes toujours très à l'aise devant les
caméras parce que tellement de
vidéosurveillance à levallois-perret que
oui c'est vrai que j'ai eu le temps de
m'y habituer oui elles y sont plus 87
aimeraient y en a partout je leur fais
toujours un petit sourire les passants
voilà donc patrick balkany vous naissez
en août 1948 oui le 16 le 16 à l'hôpital
américain de neuilly tout à fait à cette
époque votre famille est déjà pas mal
d'argent votre père qui était immigrés
juifs hongrois résistant déporté à
auschwitz s'est lancé après la guerre
dans une affaire de prêt à porter
féminin
il s'appelait réty absolue et il a bien
réussir alors donc jeunesse dorée à
neuilly non
j'ai eu une jeunesse très agréable et
puis à l'époque c'était la mode on m'a
envoyé dans un collège
pas très loin de paris il a joué en
josas ou là
j'ai passé quatre ans dans la même
chambre que michel sardou et à l'art bon
alors on faisait les 400 coups caleçon
vous c'est pas mal
on a appris la discipline veut lever des
couleurs le matin le cross son marché au
pas en fait ça s'est passé oui d'accord
mais non attends on a été formé c'est
pour ça qu'il a fait toutes ses chansons
après alain alors ensuite genève oui
vous êtes pas eu le bac que je l' ai pas
je n'ai pas eu ce que je n'ai pas passé
et puis alors là vous décidez de faire
du cinéma et c'est vrai qu'à l'époque
vous êtes grand brun sportif pourquoi à
l'époque j'étais grand brun sportback je
n'arrive toujours grand et poivre un peu
celle et sportif bah maintenant je suis
passé au golf pour ça donc c'est bien ce
que je disais alors le film s'appelle
j'ai tué raspoutine c'est un film de
robert hossein en 1967 il ya un truc on
dit que vous étiez tellement mauvais
qu'il a fallu vous doublez c'est vrai
ensuite les réseaux de votre père vous
permettent de faire le service militaire
à l'elysée c'était pratique pour nous on
est juste enfin en face de la boutique
de wahaha et j'y ai passé un an j'avais
tous les téléscripteurs et j'amenais
toutes les heures toutes les dépêches
sont à pompidou balladur joël garault
juillet etc et là vous allez rencontrer
les deux personnes les plus importantes
de votre vie votre femme isabelle smadja
est votre meilleur ami nicolas sarkozy
votre épouse vous l'avez connu lors d'un
match de boxe
c'était carlos monzon contre gratien
tonna absolument c'est un ami qui
m'avait demandé une place pour elle
voilà mais moi je suis pas reparti avec
la mise sur coup de foudre voilà alors
l'autre personne importante de votre vie
c'est évidemment nicolas sarkozy vous
l'avez rencontré en 1974
le père de nicolas sarkozy à l'époque
été aux usa et nicolas se se sont et
seuls les parents il habitait dans une
petite chambre était très malheureux et
vous alors là vous le prenez sous votre
couple vous vous l'invitez partout vous
pour payer ses études il travaillait le
samedi chez le fleuriste le dimanche
peut y vendait les classes il se
démenait pour
pour le rpr il faisait ses études de
droit sciences po et il habitait dans sa
chambre de bonne à neuilly soul avait
adopté le petit nicolas
c'est devenu mon comme mon frère bah oui
faut dire que vos deux paires étaient
hongrois dans votre bureau d'ailleurs il
ya un petit vide poches carrées en métal
argenté où il y a gravé du maire au
maire du congrès aux hongrois de l'ami
alami et c'est daté 16 août
1983 alors même quand vous alliez mal
quand vous avez été condamné à 15 mois
de prison avec sursis et deux ans
d'inéligibilité en 1996 vous savez à qui
vous me faites penser non mais j'allais
dire quelque chose de gentil la fed
pense vous me faites penser à des roues
avec une bonne grâce à lui à pas
apport intéressant d'avoir moi je me
présente pas non mais je vais dire que
sarkozy vous a pas lâché et c'est vrai
jamais voilà c'est pourtant c'est aller
mal que vous êtes parti en exil dans les
caraïbes à saint-martin je ne suis pas
parti en exil d'abord saint martin c'est
la france oui je suis parti passer deux
années sabbatiques là bas est comme ça
les mâles à levallois bat n'étaient pas
contents du nouveau maire avec tout le
monde m'a demandé de revenir je suis
revenu et j'ai été élu au premier tour
par sept voix l'a réélu à la mairie et
à l'assemblée nationale alors vous avez
beaucoup d'ennuis puis vous avez
ressuscité j'ai eu un passage qui a été
très désagréable sur des conneries que
j'avais fais de ma faute bon très bien
mais il n'y avait pas de quoi non plus
loin
me jeter aux chiens toutes les personnes
aient volé personne ne veut être clair
la volée personnes non la municipalité
un peu n'en a pas de nom pas du tout pas
du tout ça et à l'époque c'était
l'époque où je faisais venir tous les
chefs d'entreprises où j'ai transformé
la ville et au lieu de bouffer à la
mairie je les emmenais bouffer chez moi
maintenant ils bouffent à la mairie et
plus chez moi points et moi je suis au
contraire quelqu'un qui ait jamais une
note de frais je me fais jamais rien
remboursé je suis très soucieux lui
avait dit je suis l'homme le plus
honnête de la terre et je le dis non
mais c'est vrai vous l'avait dit et je
le dis et tous mes amis le savent ouais
maintenant il ya que celui qui rigole
derrière ce travail des secours sortez
moi le mec qui rigolent quand balkany
dit qu'il est honnête s'il vous plaît
mais bien sûr c'est même très important
en pratique il faut être honnête
moralement et dans tous les actes de
gestion de sa commune et des deniers
publics c'est très important moi j'ai
transformé une ville pauvre en ville
environ les pauvres pas du tout en ayant
en ayant 20 % de logements sociaux en
ayant une vraie mixité sociale et je
crois qu'au contraire levallois est
aujourd'hui l'exemple de ce que devrait
être une ville moderne 65 mille
habitants 65 mille emplois un des sièges
sociaux en veux tu en voilà mais aussi
de l'artisanat et tout ce qui fait une
ville et beaucoup d espaces verts
d'ailleurs vous ne venez plus jamais une
problème puis jamais été condamnée ce
qui prouve que la réinsertion par le
travail ça marche patrick
bien d'un problème
c'est l'endettement de levallois a la
couenne 213 millions d'euros c'est pas
spé normes
un sprint s'est ajouté un porte avions
nucléaire et non non ce qu'on a fait
c'est un superbe conservatoire qui
accueille près de 2000 élèves
refait les écoles toutes les écoles
refait une piscine un centre nautique
fait toutes les installations sportives
et culturelles nécessaires à la vie
d'une commune il ya des villes elles ont
moins d'entêtement clos elles font rien
et en plus elles ont des impôts très
élevé nous avons des impôts très bas
vous êtes à emprunter 100 millions
d'euros à la caisse des dépôts et
consignations j'ai des potes et que
sarko quand même province 100 millions
d'euros de l'appareil
alors je vais vous dire
détrompez vous détrompez-vous on
travaille avec toutes les
banques et la caisse des dépôts c'est le
banquier des collectivités un pad
levallois ils n'arrêtent pas de l'argent
à cause de ça que je veux dire ici avec
de l'argent heureusement comme un frère
comment y vivre eh bien vous avez
quelque chose a ajouté patrick balkany
oui je trouve toujours aussi perfide du
sang
nous recevons est venu plenel bonsoir
marcy bonsoir
vous connaissez tous les choix non
monsieur balkany déjà une fois sur une
émission de télévision il ya longtemps à
l'époque je tapais sur françois
mitterrand donc ça lui plaisait
maintenant que je tape sur sarkozy ça il
va pas toujours il faut qu'ils aient des
gens qui tapent sur le pouvoir ben oui
c'est comme ça qu'ils perdent les
élections
edwy plenel re bonsoir vous avez passé
25 ans au journal le monde où vous avez
terminé directeur de la rédaction
après votre départ du monde j'ai fondé
le journal numérique mediapart et vous
êtes ici ce soir pour exploser de rire à
chaque fois que patrick balkany dira
qu'il est l'homme le plus honnête de la
terre
monsieur balkany représente tout ce que
loyalement j'ai pas d'autres armes que
ma plume et que ma voix je combats ah
oui
mais il représente tout ce que je
combats depuis que je suis d'accord
très sympa nous avons le vrai visage du
sarkozysme c'est les hauts-de-seine
c'est le btp savez les premières choses
qu'il a fait quand il a été élu à la
mairie il a supprimé la bourse du
travail il a supprimé la maison des
jeunes il a supprimé tous ceux qui
incarnaient la municipalité d'avant qui
était en effet de gauche et qui ne
s'occupait pas uniquement de
l'immobilier en faisant de l'argent avec
des immeubles oui vous avez raison c'est
pendant le mandat de parfaits gens ce
qu'on a construit des cages à poules de
18 étages tout le long de la porte
bannière où on a rendu sans doute les
gens très heureux dans ses immeubles
qu'il a fallu que je refasse entièrement
avec des jardins autour pour les rendre
humain et ça avait été fait par un un
communiste qui admirait le régime qui
était alors en place en union soviétique
mais vous avez raison de le défendre je
ne défendrai pas l'union soviétique vous
savez viens vite et j'étais trop de
risque et pas vous l'êtes toujours ah
bon
vous avez des fiches alors
ils sont toujours à prendre sont dit
aussi qu'il est blessé a dit façon bien
donc vous nous pardonnerez ce soir d'un
manifeste le manifeste de médiapart
publié aux éditions galaade et qui
s'appelle combat pour une presse libre
voilà en le problème de la presse il
n'est pas compliqué d'abord une crise et
puis à la main mise du pouvoir sur les
médias vous dites que sarkozy est l'ami
des milliardaires qui contrôle les
médias privés et qu'avec la nomination
du patron de l'audiovisuel public par
lui même il a réussi dites vous un coup
d'état médiatique à froid et oui il n'a
pas d'armé ouais il a simplement nos
faiblesses ouais l'envi du pouvoir
l'envi du poste 1 j'estime beaucoup jean
luc hess par exemple a pris la
présidence de radio france mais notre
métier suppose qu'on défende son
indépendance et je pense qu'un patron de
l'audiovisuel public c'est pas le patron
d'une radio d'état c'est pas la radio ni
la télé du président c'est notre argent
c'est l'argent du public c'est pas au
président de le nommer c'est pour ça que
de vies pleines elle considère que un
média libre ne peut être dirigée que par
quelqu'un de gauche parfaitement engagé
est-ce que vous pensez que la
détestation de nicolas sarkozy pour les
journalistes traduit une sourde haine de
la démocratie
oui je pense qu'il y a chez lui un refus
de ce qu'il ne contrôle pas la
démocratie c'est les limites c'est
l'apprentissage des limites
c'est depuis montesquieu c'est le
pouvoir et contrôlés arrêté par d'autres
pouvoirs ce président qui est une sorte
d'enfant monstrueux de françois
mitterrand et jacques chirac il connaît
pas la limite c'est comme un gamin de 13
ans à qui on n'a pas appris de s'arrêter
donc il veut le sceau des autres il veut
contrôler tous
il veut le saut le saut la pelle et le
râteau vous
cette effondré là je suis effondrée
parce que aujourd'hui il suffit d'aller
sur n'importe quel blog sur pour voir
les horreurs ils peuvent être aigri
surtout les les sites s'il ya bien un
pays où il ya une vraie liberté non
seulement de la presse mais la liberté
d'expression totale c'est bien la france
vous avez le discours que vous aviez
lorsqu'il y avait une chaîne de
télévision et un ministre de
l'information qui décidait des titres le
soir au journal de 20 heures sans que je
sache madame morano elle est de la même
famille politique que monsieur balkany
et l pourchassent les gens qui disent oh
la la fête la terre cette conne sur le
web en tant que je sache moi je suis un
citoyen je veux tu 1 j'ai pas pu
poursuivre ce citoyen appelez-moi son
nom qui a dit casse toi pauv' con et qui
nous a fait un peu honte parce qu'on
peut pas le poursuivre lui il est
intouchable lui on peut lui dire toutes
les horreurs
on va voir comment ça se passerait si la
presse était libre on va faire une
interview si la presse était libre
[Musique]
alors si la presse était libre qu'est ce
qu'elle dirait qu'elle ne dit pas sur le
crash de l'avion rio paris pour
l'instant autant que je sache il n'y a
pas assez d enquête sur ce qui est à
venir c'est à dire probablement une
sacrée crise de crédibilité ouais
d'airbus d'air france puisque lee semble
bien que c'est pas un ouvrage sinon
c'est pas un attentat et au début on
nous a balancé l'histoire de lavage et
météo france
a mis une semaine à nous dire il n'y
avait pas d'orage 1
qu'est ce qu'elle dirait sur nicolas
sarkozy la presse c'était vraiment libre
si la presse était libre le président ne
pourrait pas choisir les journalistes
qui l'interviewaient la télévision il
fred authentique conférence de presse où
il ne pourrait pas humilier les
journalistes jofra on aurait le droit de
lui reposer 4 x 5 fois la même question
quand il ne répond pas à une question et
on soulignerait tous que quand il rit il
parle du voile devant barack obama il
dit un mensonge en disant que les
lycéennes et les collégiennes si elles
le veulent peuvent porter un voile ce
qui n'est pas vrai le sait où il ne sera
peut-être qui sait pas
elle en a beaucoup qui le porte qu'est
ce qu'elle dirait sur l'ump d'après si
elle était vraiment libre que ce n'est
pas un parti démocratique d'ailleurs il
n'ya plus vraiment de président que
c'est le parti du président que ce parti
n'a pas d'autonomie monsieur obama qui
contrôlent pas le parti démocrate ils
contrôlent pas la présidente du congrès
du sénat il est en négociations y
compris avec son propre parti ce n'est
pas ça mais qui n'est pas trotsky son
modèle dans la vie que obama et vous lui
posez pas de questions sur ce qu'ils
diraient sur le parti socialisme et je
les écris monsieur monsieur balkany il
faut que vous vous abonniez à mediapart
j'essaie mardi le texte le plus sévère
qui soit de toute la presse sur les
partis le parti socialiste ça s'appelle
lettre à ces socialistes qui nous
désespère donc mon indépendance vous ne
pouvez pas la mettre en cause jacques
besancenot pour vous je n'ai jamais dit
ça
non il ya notre rôle justement c'est là
où on voit votre culture le rôle de la
presse c'est pas de dire pour qui on
vote le rôle de la presse ses dettes cet
aiguillon critique c'est plus important
une presse libre c'est comme ça que les
gens peuvent être informés donc voter
parce qu'on peut mal voter parce qu'on
est mal informé la pressé libre ça vient
avant vous ça vient avant le vote pour
conclure qu est ce que la presse d'hier
est au sujet de patrick balkany c'est
l'été quelle est la part des caisses que
ça peut être elle continuerait à
enquêter notamment sur ses voyages en
afrique il est maire de levallois perret
ouais il n'est pas secrétaire à la
françafrique oui ils n'arrêtent pas de
se balader là bas je suis la rive de la
commission de faire du profit
mais je suis vice-président d'orange y
aller plus souvent à
simplement monsieur guéant secrétaire
général de l'elysée a dit que patrick
balkany n'était pas missionné
officiellement que finir et la barre qui
va pour le plaisir un patrie dans je le
fais
je vais en tant que parlementaires
membres de la mission mes affaires
étrangères
[Applaudissements]
bien alors patrick balkany souvent quand
on parle de vous on emploie le terme
sulfureux je sais pas très bien pourquoi
en souvenir de tous ces problèmes et
pour vraiment prouver le contraire on va
faire une interview balkany a aussi des
bons côtés
[Musique]
est ce que vous aimez les enfants je les
adore je voyais je vais être grand père
pour la deuxième voilà cet été tu vois
est ce que vous aimez les animaux j'ai
deux chiens et deux chats revoilà est-ce
que vous nourrissez les oiseaux
je nourris les oiseaux
je m'occupe de tout et même à la loi il
ya des pigeonniers est-ce que prison
vous donner de l'argent des associations
caritatives j'en entends bien entendu
est-ce que vous aidez les vieilles dames
à traverser la rue je vais vous dire non
seulement je les aide à traverser la rue
mais parfois c'est elle qui traverse de
l'autre côté pour venir m'embrasser
bien entendu vous fait les plus gros
efforts pour sauver la planète patrick
écoutez je vais vous donner un petit
exemple un tiers de levallois et
chauffée uniquement par leur traitement
les ordures ménagères sans fumée ce
montant vient tu vois qu'il a baissé il
a aussi ses bons côtés est ce que vous
êtes marrants
demandé à mes amis vous connaissez des
blagues j'en connais didier une blague
non point bas non parce que moi j'aime
les blagues longue avec accent
maintenant je vous raconterai après
est-ce que vous prêtez vos dvd je les
donne voilà est-ce que vous roulez des
pétards pour vos potes je n'ai jamais
fumé de pétain a ravie jamais à ça c'est
un mauvais côté en sueur
conclusion balkany a aussi ses bons
coups
être sûr de ne rien rater de li na l'a
redit tube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux